they are carefully designed to keep out
the rising sea
more than 70 000 concrete blocks will
strengthen the upslide deck and protect
the netherlands against storms and high
waves
made with recycled material from the old
dike every single one of the
thousand five hundred kilogram blocks
contains an electronic chip
you know when you have a super super
super storm
and there is somewhere some issue with
one of these blocks or so it's a little
bit
gum down or cracked or something then we
can trace it
and find out where which block it is
take it out when construction began in
the 1920s many did not believe the dutch
could close off an entire sea
and build a 32 kilometer long dike
thousands of people worked on the
project one stone
at a time it was a gigantic project
nearly a century ago and it's a mega
project once again
it will take seven years before the
offsload dike will be strong enough
again
but it is predicted they will only
protect the dutch heartland against the
sea until 2050.
after that more reinforcements are
likely needed
people were protesting against the
construction of the dike in the early
1900s
could not have guessed how crucial it
would be in the future
fishing communities surrounding the
southern sea lost their source of income
when it turned into a sweetwater lake
behind the dyed part of the sea bottom
were reclaimed and islands disappeared
yuri vandenberg's grandfather was among
those protesting against the project
aldi mentioned all these people back
then could have looked into the future
and would see how much welfare it has
brought
and how it has taken our country forward
they would not have protested
reclaiming land has been a huge victory
for the netherlands
from a country importing food the
netherlands turned into an exporter
well we are now at at the bottom of the
saudis hay so
they made a huge boulder at the cyrus
and
it is the the biggest border of the
world historians say countries adapting
to a changing climate can learn
important lessons from the dutch
experience after building the offslide
day
so these fishery communities had a very
strong sense of community
and that made them very resilient
against
before this big change so if you have a
community that has a
very strong sense togetherness they are
more resilient
and resilience will be needed because in
30 years this barrier might not be high
enough once again
what can you do if if you need a
stronger diet
a higher diet you call us again and we
make it higher
[Laughter]
when the dutch built it died they wanted
to prove that in order to obtain land
you don't need to go to war
not realizing that a different battle
against rising sea levels
was just around the corner step faster
than al jazeera
on the offsload date